ただいま開いた口お久しぶりに大学に行ってきましたあのねぇねぇ
疲れるね以上に使えるライブがつかれるって言うじゃないんですけども久しぶりにさあ
いつも行けない場所に行っていろんな人で粒疲れるわけっすよ
疲れた卒業論文の中間発表生の d 発表ではなかったんですけどもなんだかあなたは
なりました
が良かったよよかったけどね遊べちゃうわけですよガッコがブレーダー
4日個入っちゃう午後から夕方に終わったんでは帰って来て待ってるそれか発表で
ちょっと色々置いコペンっていうことを疲れたので今日はみなさんお待ちかね質問
コーナーの募集でございます
学校が始まった田治米社長だけど何か質問ある
なんか月レギュラーなやっぱね謎いつもコーナー好評なんですよ
なんでだろう前回の雑用 youtube のこの動画のコメント欄でも質問を募集し
ます結構りけん堂方ですね今回はちょっと実験的に twitter の方でも募集し
ます
8下旬のコメントなどを twitter で募集するんですけどもう youtube
の方はいつものでこちらにコメントをしてください
twitter の方は僕に着いたらカウントにコーディングを送るじゃなくて
ハッシュだけ歌手
あるつけて集め質問コーナーこれをつけて室に連れてくれるとその僕が日で見えます僕
のアカウントにビッグとしてねそのメッセージとか送るとセダンのメッセージが見れ
ないけど
この橋だけこれをつけてぽ県の質問をついたり書いてください youtube アイス
を取りコメントパパってやるだけで ok です
月曜日母は使いだったよでもなんかねああ
なんかもうでも学生最後なんだなぁと思ってね頑張って大学行こうかなと思います
学校比較ああっ僕はやっぱりみんなにどうぞを出してる顔としてもっとこう
みんながお手本にならできる学校てほしいな
マットマット学校行きたーーーい
ブービー式えっは維持
ダンスこのかけましたでしょうかもうほんとなんでもいいです毎回の通りなんでおいい
ですおふざけた質問からずだけど質問するだけだ質問からふざけば質問何でも聴きます
まず質も良いですけどもまぁ楽しくね質問ポーランドが取れればいいなと思っており
ます
五感をね部署日だから指輪では皆さん私も小待ちしておりますじゃあ
me
tan
んん